bonjour Patrick Mignola vous présidiez
avant les précédentes élections
législatives le groupe modem à
l'Assemblée nationale comment va ce
modem ce matin donc vous êtes le
vice-président le porte-parole est-ce
que vous êtes satisfait de ce
gouvernement qui comprend finalement
quatre membres de votre parti comme le
précédent alors comment on se porte je
il y a pas de suspense on est toujours
dans la majorité parce que certaines
questions avit pu se poser quand
François baayerou est arrivé au
ministère de l'Agriculture chez Marc
fenau il y a 2 jours
il avait fait un certain nombre
d'observations des points de vigilance
on va sans doute y revenir sur le la
politique à conduire mais à aucun moment
il était question de sortir de la
majorité donc c'est plutôt une
satisfaction que le gouvernement trouve
un un équilibre et une unité dans la
diversité des opinions mais
comprenons-nous vous vous évoquiez
François baayerou mardi soir mercredi
soir pardon au ministère de
l'Agriculture il n'y a pas cette dérive
vers une technocratie gestionnaire je
reprense ces termes parce que ce sont
les siens dans ce gouvernement puisque
vous y participez c'est évidemment un
point de vigilance je vberg vous voyez
bien euh le la situation démocratique
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons euh on
est obligé les uns et les autres de se
poser les bonnes questions euh il y a
50 % d'abstention à peu près à toutes
les élections il on annonce la même
chose pour les prochaines élections
européennes il y a ce sentiment d'un
d'un divorce entre le pouvoir centralisé
et les territoires et c'est pas interdit
en politique de d'avoir de temps en
temps un exercice d'humilité en se
disant effectivement ça fait 7 ans qu'on
est au responsab
nous en prenons notre part mais on n'est
pas parvenu à recréer un lien de
confiance avec les Françaises et les
Français entre les Françaises et les
Français et l'action politique néanmoins
vous restez c'est un constat un peu
paradoxal c'est-à-dire vous critiquez
fortement via François Baayou et en même
temps vous continuer à à participer
mais une critique c'est une critique je
vous le dis dans laquelle nous nous
incluons nous-mêm il faut savoir se
remettre en question saz les politiques
qui viennent vous voir et qui vous
expliquent qu'ils ont des solutions
toutes faites surtout
c'est c'est pas des gens auxquels les
Français peuvent faire confiance dans la
durée nous disons aujourd'hui une chose
simple nous avons un devoir de vigilance
pour que la démocratie française ne se
délite pas et au fond c'est ce qu'a dit
François Baou vous savez c'est très
facile de caricaturer un peu comme comme
les tractes du RPR dans les années 2000
que François baillerou fait un coup de
sang ou un coup de gueule ou un coup de
pression je pense qu' vre dans votre
camp Bange votre collègue
vreit j'adore Jean-Louis qui a un statut
particulier au sein du modemme mais il y
a pas eu une bronca un petit peu par
rapport à la au cavalier seul de
François Baayou qui n'avait pas
consulté ça n'a pas été le cas parce que
nous on on participe pas à cette œuvre
de caricature qui consiste à dire que
quand on est en désaccord ou quand on a
des points de vigilance dans une
majorité c'est forcément dans un calcul
il y avait pas là esprit de marchandage
de toute façon on avait quatre ministres
on a toujours quatre ministres nous
étions dans la majorité nous y sommes
encore on a bien l'intention d'y
travailler et de réussir mais qui soit
permis is de formuler ce qu'au fond
toutes les Françaises et tous les
Français pensent on a besoin de
réconciliation dans ce pays on a besoin
de faire baisser la
pression VI on a l'impression qu'à
partir du moment où il y a eu la relaxe
de François baayerou on en reparlera
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure puisque le
procureur a
demandé un nouveau un nouvel examen en
appel pourquoi ne s'est-il pas exprimé
aussi fortement avant alors que le le
modem participe à ses gouvernements
depuis 7 ans comme vous l' rappé
pression inverse c'est dire ça fait ça
fait très longtemps qu'on parle de ce
sujet et et de façon très concrète
comment demain on arrivera mieux à
représenter les Français dans les
élections faut bien qu'on ouvre le grand
dossier des institutions des modes de
scrutin de la proportionnelle tout le
monde l'attend il faut bien que on
arrive à faire de la simplification de
ce qu'on appelle le millefeuil
territorial si vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui comprend comment les collectivités
sont organisées et savoir qui fait quoi
fait Ann nos maires sur le terrain sont
en grande difficulté parce que
aujourd'hui on vient les voir autant
comme mire que comme officier orienteur
pour comprendre comment les
administrations fonctionnent tous ces
éléments ça fait longtemps qu'on le dit
alors peut-être en effet que que depuis
qu'il y a eu une relax dans cette
affaire qui nous pourrissait la vie
depuis 7 ans le la voix de François
Baayou est un peu plus sonore
mais après la relaxe est-ce que le
cauchemar dont a parlé François Baayou
recommence du fait qu'il va y avoir donc
une nouvelle une nouvelle procédure un
nouveau procès c'est moi je j'utilise
pas de mots comme acharnement mais je je
constate qu'il y a une forme d'assiduité
en tout cas de justice sur ces sujets
d'autant que le les accusations qui
étaient portées contre nous l'était
d'accusateurs devenus des ennemis
politiques donc on on continuera de se
défendre mais effectivement après vous
pensez que c'est une décision politique
après c ans pas du tout pas du tout moi
je pense
que les accusations étaient évidemment
portées par des personnes qui sont
devenues des ennemis politiques donc il
était permis de douter de leurs
affirmations au demeurant c'est ce que
le tribunal a conclu après 7 ans
d'enquête et 6 semaines d'audience mais
mais pour revenir à François
Baayou je veux pas qu'on
caricature cette idée selon laquelle
quand on exprime un désaccord ou un
point de vigilance on serait forcément
dans un dans un bras de fer malvenu je
crois que la vie politique aujourd'hui
elle tient des discours un peu trop
asceptisés ou parfois totalement
radicalisé quand il s'agit des extrêmes
non de temps en temps c'est bien de se
faire l'écho de ce qui est ressenti sur
le terrain on a parlé de Jeanlou
bourlange à l'instant vous vous le savez
vous ne l'ignorez pas y compris dans
votre camp certains estiment néanmoins
qu'il a quand même pensé à sa carrière
politique il a 72 ans il n'a pas exclu
de se présenter à la prochaine élection
présidentielle est-ce que vous c'est un
scénario qui vous paraît
crédible et envisageable toute personne
engagée dans la vie politique a envie
d'assumer des responsabilités pour son
pays il l'a redit au début de cette
semaine c'est pas une immense annonce
que je suis en train de de vous faire
ici mais moi je recommande à tout le
monde de toute façon de travailler au
jour le jour les Français attendent des
réponses pour la semaine prochaine et
pas qu'on conjecture sans cesse sur 2027
c'est lui c'est lui-même qui a dit que
les scénarios étaient encore ouverts je
vais vous faire une confidence je crois
que quand il en parle c'est parce que
vous et vos confrères lui posz la
question est-ce que vous fait avec une
belle constance est-ce que vous faites
partie de ceux qui considèrent que le
gouvernement première mouture il a été
désormais étaufé penché trop à droite il
y a eu des critiques au modem notamment
après les nominations de Rachid Dati de
Catherine vauterin est-ce que finalement
c'était cela aussi que vous dénonciez à
travers le le coup de gueule pardon de
François Baayou oui il s'agissait de
retrouver au fond ce qui était
l'inspiration de du macronz c'est pas en
mettant des des coups de barre à droite
ou des coups de barre à gauche qu'on
règle les problèmes des Français au fond
cet esprit de de dépassement où on
s'efforce de de prendre les problèmes
les uns après les autres et de les
régler de fond en comble et de montrer
aux Français que la politique ça sert
encore à quelque chose c'était ça
l'inspiration initiale du macronisme
c'est ce que nous avons réclamé vous sa
un gouvernement c'est trois choses
régler des problèmes au jour le jour et
et en ce moment il y a vraiment de quoi
faire on l' encore vu avec la crise
agricole euh c'est ensuite avoir une
vision un cap un avenir comment on met
plus de justice dans un pays et enfin
c'est organiser la réconciliation et ça
c'est un travail de tous les jours entre
des Français qui n'y croient plus mais
qui malgré tout sont des passionnés de
politique pardon mais cette ces Français
qui n'y croient plus cette déconnexion
on a l'impression parce que François
Baayou encore une fois c'est vous qui
êtes là ce matin mais vous êtes son ami
vous êtes son porte-parole puisque vous
êtes le porte-parole du MoDem il l'a
notamment dénoncé à travers la
composition jusqu'à hier soir du
gouvernement avec que des ministres ou
presque franciliens aucun ministre du
Sud de la loi et il n'en faisait pas
mystère il considérait que Gabriel Atal
le Premier ministre manquait
d'expérience donc toutes ces critiques
vous les avez entendu est-ce qu'elles
sont réelles est-ce que par exemple il y
a une responsabilité dans le choix de
Gabriel Atal il était important que
Gabriel Atal que je connais bien et dont
jeis souhaite le la pleine
réussite fe ce
rééquilibrageement également
géographique non mais je crois qu'il a
fait il a fait une très bonne entrée en
matière et au fond quand on on regarde
ce rééquilibrage politique et ce
rééquilibrage géographique pour que ce
gouvernement ressemble un peu plus à la
France ben je crois que le le bon pas a
été franchi hier quand quand je je vois
arriver par exemple de nouveaux
ministres savoyard comme mon ami Marina
Ferrari je je suis très heureux de voir
que voilà dans le dans les les longues
traditions de représentation des régions
bah ça y est désormais il y aura des
interlocuteurs partout dans le pays vous
pensez néanmoins que cette affaire va
laisser des traces on pense notamment à
l'arrivée de Nicole Boubé à l'éducation
nationale après un mois de psychodrame
autour des maladresses puisquelle l'a
elle-même reconnue d'Amélie oua ctera
qu'est-ce qui va rester de cette
séquence au
fond je sais pas ce qui restera mais
désormais notre travail c'est de régler
les problèmes du quotidien des Français
il y a besoin de travailler sur l'école
et sur la santé qui étaient les deux
grandes priorités du président de la
République candidat en 2022 aujourd'hui
il faut que on soit au rendez-vous des
des réponses pour les Françaises et les
Français sur les sujets de du transport
sur les sujets du logement euh et c'est
désormais dans le concret et plus dans
le dans le commentaire dans le
commentaire vous avez présidé le groupe
modem euh lorsque vous étiez député vous
souhaitez désormais que ce euh groupe
vote au cas par cas ou qu'il soit
toujours au rendez-vous de la majorité
qu'il soit solidaire dans tous les cas
il y a eu un communiqué hier et loan qui
était pas dans la ligne Baou le principe
même du du Mouvement Démocrate c'est une
liberté de vote ouais euh mais on voit
que nonobstant la liberté de vote qui
qui est consubstantielle chez nous on se
retrouve toujours dans l'unité quand
l'essentiel est en jeu donc on se pose
pas la question de d'une tactique au
coup par coup on voote ce qui est utile
important pour le pays et et dans ce
mouvement politique qui vient de loin de
la démocratie chrétienne
euh je crois qu'on garde une forme de
constance qui est entendue par les
Français et bien on verra dans les
prochains jours merci beaucoup Patrick
minignola